tous ces réfugiés ne peuvent pas
transporter grand chose avec eux mais la
plupart possèdent au moins un téléphone
intelligent
ce qui n'est pas un luxe vraiment ils en
ont absolument besoin durant leur
périlleux voyage pour eux un outil qui
souvent peut faire la différence entre
la vie et la mort
bonsoir mathieu que je sais c'est un
outil très important indispensable
indispensable ça leur permet de ne
jamais être totalement déracinés au mois
d'août dernier ayant réfugiés syriens
résumé la faire à la fp il a dit écoute
et on peut avoir faim mais on ne peut
pas ne pas avoir de téléphone dit plus
importante au téléphone que la
nourriture ça dit tout oui ça sert à
toutes sortes de choses assez réducteur
de choses non par exemple on a vu
récemment par exemple un bateau dont le
moteur s'était éteint dans la nuit en
plein milieu de la mer egée des dizaines
de réfugiés avaient leur téléphone et
ils ont illuminé leur écran tous en même
temps dans le noir pour alerter la
garde-côte ça peut aussi prendre cet
appel à l'aide
la forme d'un message sur l'application
ou whatsapp le bateau est en train de
couler on envoie un message à la garde
côtière et donc comme sont peu le giron
peu léger organisé pour les sauver et
pas besoin de vous dire que le sac de
plastique hermétique fait aussi partie
des essentiels qu'on doit avoir avec
nous quand on pense à tous ces naufrages
malheureusement mais comment ils font
pour trouver justement les numéros de
téléphone les groupes facebook sont très
importants les réfugiés sont massivement
sur facebook et des centaines de groupes
facebook
qu'est ce qu'on va chercher là dessus
l'information sur les points de passage
les numéros des autorités les bons et
les moins bons passeurs les prix eux
mêmes des ong qui met sur pied le long
des routes qui sont empruntées par les
migrants
ddd des zones où sans fil pour que les
gens puissent aller chercher les
messages puissent envoyer des messages
peuvent plus tenir leurs familles à jour
sur leur périple
ouais là où ils sont ils les appellent
il ya aussi ils peuvent s'en servait
aussi pour traduire parce que quand ils
arrivent dans les pays où la langue
l'épaule véhicule ça sert à plein de
choses et ça sert également aussi à
débusquer parce que vous savez que sur
facebook des groupes des mauvaises
agences de voyages qui promettent mer et
monde aux réfugiés et dont facebook
ferme régulièrement des pages de ses
agences là parce qu'on leur
leur exigent des prix exorbitants et on
les envoie sont des coquilles de noix
alors il ya des gens dans les pays en
europe qui disait pourquoi on devrait
intégrer et accueillir chez nous des
gens qui peuvent se payer des téléphones
cellulaires leur dise a contrario on ne
peut pas se payer le luxe de ne pas en
avoir
il faut dire que dans ces pays là les
téléphones cellulaires coûte moins cher
beaucoup utilisent aussi des
applications de sont moins gourmandes en
dernier mot puis pour eux comme vous
dites si bien si la survie reçus nous
l'a souvent la différence entre la vie
et la mort merci monsieur au plaisir